chrissy teigen is finally speaking out
addressing her past behavior on social
media
i'd like to think that in the past few
years i've kind of i've pulled back
definitely on on what i
like to say last month the mom of two
came under fire
after past tweets resurfaced of the star
sending disparaging comments to courtney
stodden who told the daily beast quote
she wouldn't just publicly tweet about
wanting me to take a dirt
nap but would privately dm me and tell
me to kill myself
now chrissy is addressing the scandal in
a lengthy essay
revealing she's in the process of
privately reaching out to other people
she is insulted
admitting she's truly ashamed and that
there's no excuse for her behavior
thanks to twitter and instagram yeah it
lives forever
the cookbook author writes my targets
didn't deserve them
no one does many of them needed empathy
kindness
understanding and support not my
meanness
masquerading as a kind of casual edgy
humor
i was a troll full stop and i am so
sorry
i'm 100 a twitter and instagram addict
if i were to pick one it would be
twitter
but i'm not kidding it's a it's a
constant feed
she also goes on to question her motives
at the time revealing she now cringes to
her core when she thinks about her past
words have consequences and there are
real people behind the twitter handles i
went after
i wasn't just attacking some random
avatar but hurting young women
some who were still girls who had
feelings how could i not stop and think
of that
a lot of times there are things that i
want to say but and there's things that
i believe
but i don't necessarily want to deal
with you know the backlash and things
anymore so um
i'm getting a little smarter with that
stuff too but i don't know i just try to
have fun and
and be able to share with people like
this i have a crazy life
just moments after her blog went live
fashion designer michael costello shared
his own allegations of being bullied by
chrissy
after she accused him of making a racist
comment that he says was actually
photoshopped on the internet
he claims she threatened to make sure
his career was over leading him to
contemplate suicide
chrissy has yet to respond to michael's
claims but in the essay she makes it
clear
she is not seeking empathy from her
victims there's no justification for my
behavior
i'm not a victim here the subjects of
your sympathy
and mine should be those i put down
you